BTS answers you're burning fan questions
plus we're hanging out with smosh's ian
hecox happy Friday everybody what a week
it has been I'm gonna get right to it
because I've left the BTS army hanging
long enough we asked you guys to send us
your questions for the kpop sensations
and it was so so hard to pick but here
were some of our favorite burning
questions we got to ask the guy so I
have some questions from the fans we got
thousands and thousands of fans asking
us to ask you a couple questions so
what's your what's your favorite song
right now can be like a bale of Coors
like me and Jo favorite song are you
liking the food in America that a lot of
people are know if you've been to in and
out like four years ago okay you gotta
come back first time yeah where we just
arrived at the airport and then we had
you guys are like brothers is there a
habit that gets on your guy's nerves you
always play games and but with
microphones so I he's always like I'm
sharing my room with him oh so he's loud
yes better noise fine so I think we got
a move on today yeah or something right
what do you guys see the group and BTS
in ten years
maybe like bulletproof adults or
something you'll be uncle's any plans
for any solo projects I know a lot of
people want to know about Jay hopes
mixtape oh it's coming soon yeah
very beat stuff right yeah coming soon
any plans for any other solo projects
he's got his studio room just got his
new yeah I started to produce some beads
so maybe we can't expect some alright
alright if you guys could say anything
to your younger selves you know when you
were just starting the group what would
it be
please change your name what you did
yeah let's change your hair alright why
did why did you change your name that
came from actually like song that I made
from like 2012 there was a some like
phrase like rap monster and I just I
thought it was cool but you know as I
grow up and as I came to America I think
it felt like something like too much and
you know like so like I just abbreviated
to RM and just it could symbolize many
thing you could have more spectrums in
it what does it mean to you right now um
I don't know like real me or something I
love they all notice your hair change
the hair color you like it what was that
what inspired the change in your hair
color I did it for AMA yeah red color
fight your j-hope and the rest of the
group are definitely planning on
bringing the fire at this weekend
American Music Awards make sure you guys
do not miss their us TV debut
performance I was at the rehearsal and
I'm telling you right now it's gonna be
epic all right we've got another Friday
treat for you guys though you may know
Ian Hecox as the mastermind behind
comedy powerhouse Smosh
well Smosh just launched their first
long-form show in the channels 12 year
history and Ian stopped by to give our
pal ash Cross in a taste of the new game
series and what the future holds were
smart
hello everybody we've got a special
guest today Ian Hecox fellow mash here
yeah working on a new project a new game
show that's very fun yeah you posted
that and tell me about it so we realized
that anybody's Twitter from two or three
years ago is
is very very awkward there's some things
that uh that you might have said two
years ago that maybe nowadays you could
say that I probably said that so we made
an entire game show around that so we've
we've taken a lot of we've invited some
of our favorite youtubers to be on our
show and then we throw their old tweets
at their faces Gabby on October 7th 2012
you tweeted I haven't blanked myself in
a while no retweets and like go and see
it is very funny so you posted that
Smosh was kind of moving in a different
direction and you've kind of had a big
years with Anthony leaving what is the
future like are you still gonna do
sketches or is this kind of the yeah
Channel yeah we realized that after we
put the we we we made an announcement
video when we said that we're taking
Smosh in a new direction we're making
you posted that then we realize
definitely put it out we're like oh this
makes it sound like we're only gonna do
this no we're still doing sketches but
we didn't make that clear so a lot of
people I think freaked out they're like
the hood whoo what about the sketches
like I said and it's like no no we're
still doing that but then we're also
doing the game show so yeah we're just
trying new things so I'm gonna steal one
of your segments okay okay so we are
going to be you have to pay us for that
yeah of course of course
residual yeah um we're gonna read some
celeb tweets and we're gonna decide
whether or not they're funny oh and then
if you would like to guess who the
celebrity is go ahead and take a step
okay great mmm number one mmm
does anyone think global warming is a
good thing I love Lady gaga I think
she's a really interesting artist that's
not funny
but I would say I would say I know cher
makes a lot of really incoherent tweets
something's gonna say how Cher you know
what it was Britney Spears oh yeah she
makes them no yes she makes some weird
tweets - yeah Graham is just it makes
outside Cowabunga dude s I'm so pumped
to be on this surfing kick
who else surfs out there gnarly day in
the h2o rotten with
[Music]
these are jokes they are funny I'm just
gonna have to guess that was Cole
Sprouse Kim Kardashian what has she ever
been on a surfboard hi I'm in England
and I pulled the fire alarm because I
thought I was flushing the toilet Oh
again it's not a joke nothing's pretty
funny yeah who Justin Bieber it sounds
like a Bieber thing no ain't no but
Bieber wouldn't do it accidentally he
would do it intentionally yeah he won
yeah I'm definitely a little John and
you know what no my mistake that's
actually my tweet oh really
yeah you do that yeah Wow here's a week
ago I thanks to Ian for stopping by the
daily Denny and a very special shout-out
to the BTS army who showed us nothing
but love this week thank you guys so
much you really are the best fans we'll
be back on Monday with an all-new daily
Dani so ring that Bell and have a good
weekend goodbye
[Music]